so given what happens in this movie I'm
curious what is your technology vice if
Chuckie got a hold of something you use
every day in your life what would he be
able to get us phones of course like our
phone like that's the thing that
terrifies me is like because I'm so like
conspiracy theorists when it comes to
like technology like I always wait to
upgrade like I don't everyone alike I
always try to hold off to the last
minute and it inevitably kind of gets
you in a chokehold and you got to do it
all right my phone myself the thumbprint
cuz I was there I don't want face I
don't want my face everywhere I don't
want that like yeah like you think
there's always a software update like
there's nothing no matter what like and
your phone will just do it while you're
asleep like it's like it I don't like it
I think about it all the time but I'm a
huge sucker when the new thing comes out
so ignition is a lot of course
absolutely because like that's just like
like that's what's so funny like you
know like you don't have to be a child
to have toys like now we're adults and
all our technology is art there are toys
all the toys are the same it's like my
toy is the phone and my teeny tiny
little cousins are sitting there tablets
all the time like just unaware of what's
going on about like that's yeah that's
just the way the world knows all right
spinning that question a little what is
the weirdest piece of tech that you use
all the time that Chucky could use to
kill someone
mm-hm I just got a war oh no I got this
like toothbrush Waterpik combo that like
it's really but like I was like what do
you do floss me to death like we're like
what but like you could I have a
terrible fear of the dentists and nuts
are very noise and horror movies anymore
but the dentist is still the thing that
terrifies me to the core so that would
be my worst nightmare yeah like that's
why it's like it was like you got ahold
of like like could use my oral hygiene
like that's just like that's awful it
really is my worst thing I could think
of it was my cat has a litter robot and
I feel like there's something like
really freaky and weird like I robot
vacuum cleaners that I will not do that
I was like I don't like that I don't
like that
I don't like that it's just like no I'm
not doing that so he's reading in the
press notes that you are the horror guy
and I have a horror obsession and me
plus my witching hour co-host at
Collider we are the horror ladies so I
have to ask you where did it start what
was the gateway horror movie that made
you a fan you wanna know the very first
movie I ever saw in my life like I think
I was four years old and my sisters took
me to this movie called Friday the 13th
part 6 Jason lives which to this day is
still one of my favorites like I can
watch that movie all day long but I was
like literally for watching Jason turn a
woman's head all the way around 360 and
like I didn't cry I wasn't sad I was
like this is actually really cool like
so I just just was just so obsessed with
them because I feel like horror movies
have to do a couple of things like you
have to have impeccable acting you have
to have a really good story but you
don't mean it could be gory or not but
like you really want to like there
should be somebody in the store you care
about but there should always be the
impending like knowing around the corner
that anybody could go in any moment and
what I really loved about I mean like
horror movies of the 80s especially the
80s like that whole slasher thing coming
in it was so much fun like you like you
literally have to have commentary
throughout the whole movie because it's
just like can you believe that that just
happened like can't you and I don't know
like I just always I always thought that
like with the real world was scarier
than what we were watching you know what
I mean like that's why I kind of liked
hormones because I fully they were
commentary on the world we live in
society all the time you know like the
final girl you know if you smoke weed or
you have sex we've got to die and I'm
like okay like okay and also like what
you're also showing us like like men are
crazy like it's always the women like
you having to overcome like this person
that just like walks really slowly and
it's like already like it just I thought
it was like the movies training me well
I'm convinced that should any of these
scenarios actually happen I would be the
one to survive myself I do but that's
why else it's a child's play because it
was like you know in a horror movies
black people we don't make it that long
nor do we have like any kind of
character development so like when I saw
this I was like yep I'm in character
development one of my favorite scenes in
this movie is when the three of you are
having dinner together just the
chemistry in that particular moment is
through the roof do you guys get to play
around and yeah I mean large is really
cool like he'll just set the camera up
and like let you go and I remember doing
that scene with Gabriel and Carly's like
and and you know like because like the
parallels between Andy and micro very
much the same these men who like are
from single mom homes and like don't
really have a lot of friends and I felt
like that scene was literally you
getting a chance to watch Andy and Mike
really like come together while there is
this present on the table - oh good like
there's a print like it's just you know
yeah like that's a big testament to Lars
who really gave us like you know like my
sister's just play and create these
relationships because at the end of the
day this movie is really about
friendship like honestly and it really
does come down to friendship given the
fact that we are definitely gonna have
more iconic / or franchises rebooted in
the future from your experience working
on this if you could tell a filmmaker
who's about to do that any single piece
of advice that would help them reboot a
franchise the right way what would it be
make sure that the relationships are
genuine like honestly like really like
really make sure that you actually care
about the people that you're about to
kill and with everything you have coming
up especially because after I first saw
you in Atlanta it seems like ever since
then you're just you're not even just
adding one great film after the next to
your resume you're joining all of these
iconic franchises doesn't ever hit a
point anymore where you're standing
there on set or you sign on for
something new and you're like wow I
can't believe I'm a part of this I hope
I feel that all the time like that
that's literally like why I do what I do
I'm the biggest nerd you have ever met
in your life like I used to have child's
play comic books like that's stickers
like all that stuff and I think that
that's what's so great about his journey
is like I'm constantly always like a
nerd of what I
and that's why I love doing it you know
I mean I'm doing it for those other
nerds out there too or just like yeah
man like it's just always gonna be fun
and I want it to always be that way you
feel it you told me that at the
spider-verse don't get about this movie
haven't stopped thinking about it and I
finally saw it I'm like you're right
yeah I had a blast yeah yes that's the
whole point of it so like if you give me
a script that says child's play I'm
going to do it any movie props or
memorabilia at home especially from the
scarier stuff like this um you know
what's really funny I didn't take
anything from set but a lot of my
friends know how much I care about
child's play so I have friends crocheted
me things with Chucky you know what I
mean like get magnets I've got pins and
I like to collect pins so I'm glad I
have like the good guy doll pins like
but like it's stuff like that because
like my friends know how much I care
about like this stuff and how much of a
nerd I am so I have a lot of Chucky
esque stuff yeah